maxine waters perhaps the biggest
scumbag in congress
i mean there's a lot of competition for
that title but i i i would maybe give
her
i would you know she's in the the top
three certainly she's in the wrong
um anyway she traveled to minnesota
she traveled from dc to minnesota to
incite a riot and intimidate jurors
that's what she did
a whole series of felonies she committed
and
she did it on video for everyone to see
we can all watch it we'll watch it right
now here it is
and so yes i would like to see
the bill in congress pass on police
reform
but i know that the right wing the
racist
are opposed to it and i don't know
what's going to happen to it
but i know this we've got to stay in the
street
and we've got to we've got to demand
justice as a black man despite
all of the efforts i feel like nothing
changes
and george floyd is waking so many
people up yet nothing has happened just
but
you know despite the rhetoric like what
what needs to happen that's different
this year
yeah and all the years we are looking
for a guilty verdict
i am very hopeful and i hope
that we're going to get a verdict
that is say guilty guilty guilty and if
we don't
we cannot go away and not just
manslaughter right i mean
oh no not manchester united no no no
this is this is guilty
for murder i don't know whether it's in
the first degree but as far as i'm
concerned is supposed to be congressman
what happens if we do not go
get what you just told what should the
people do what's your protesters on the
street
i didn't hear you what happens what
should protesters do
well we got to stay on the street uh and
we've got to get more
active we've got to get more
confrontational
we've got to make sure that they they
know that we need business
more confrontational can you get more
confrontational than burning buildings
down well we're going to find out
by the way she's calling for chauvin to
be found guilty of a charge that he's
not
charged with he's not charged with
premeditating murder he's not charged
with first-degree murder
um that's what she wants so she's
already setting it up
and doing so intentionally of course
that no matter what
i mean he could be found guilty on every
single charge
and that's not gonna be enough because
he's not he wasn't charged with enough
crimes as far as she's concerned
so she's already setting that up
and of course if you know needless to
say if you're if you're
actually worried about truth and justice
and
all that kind of stuff it doesn't make
any sense if you leave aside
the blatant jury intimidation jury
tampering she's doing here
like she she left it's not even that
she's given a press conference in dc
that'd be bad enough she went to the
community
she went to the city where this trial is
happening she went to the community
where these jurors
live and said if you don't give us a
guilty verdict
if you don't in fact conjure up a charge
that doesn't exist and
convict him on that um
then we're going to be more
confrontational quote unquote wink wink
wink
but if even like leaving aside
all the many crimes she committed there
um obviously it doesn't make any sense
if you actually care about truth and
justice to be protesting
ahead of the jury verdict he was charged
we he had a trial that's what we do in
this country
and now the jury is gonna weigh the
evidence and come to a determination
that's the way it's supposed to work
you know to demand a certain verdict
doesn't make any sense
if you cared about truth and justice
which obviously they don't
and this is why we know look we've
closing arguments today
but the case has been presented right so
we can we can say now officially
if you've been following this the trial
as i have
that we have seen the state present its
whole case
and um i was not convinced by the
state's case all
the whole way but i you know i i at
least
i'm the one preaching we have to let the
trial play out so i tried to allow that
to happen
thinking maybe i didn't think it was
going to happen but maybe they'll
somewhere along the line they'll come up
with uh with with compelling evidence
they never did
and so now we can say after the trial's
already happened
we've seen the state present its case it
doesn't really have a case
if the jury is making this decision
based on the evidence
they would acquit on all charges
not because they think derek chovin is a
great guy not because they want him to
be back on the police force
not even because they you know they
they're they're categorically rejecting
the idea that he murdered george floyd
but just because there's just bundles of
reasonable doubt here reasonable doubt
all over the place through every facet
it is at least i think we can say this
like being as conservative
as we can it is at least
reasonably plausible even now after
seeing the state's evidence
that george floyd died of a drug
overdose and nothing chauvin did caused
it
that that remain even now that remains a
reasonable possibility
which means he should be acquitted but
um i just don't see that happening
because these jurors think about the
situation they're in i
first of all i i i
if it were me there's no way i would
allow myself to be on that jury
like i would say whatever i had to be to
say to not be on it
but the situation there now is um
this is happening in their community
this is where they live
and probably they're screwed no matter
what because like i like we said like i
said
shelvin isn't charged with first degree
murder and that's what these morons in
the street want
and because they're morons or in the
case of maxine waters dishonest scumbags
and also a [ __ ]
they're going gonna blame the jury for
the fact that he's not convicted of
first-degree murder no matter what
happens
but if they were to acquit on all
charges here's what they know is gonna
happen
their lives are ruined and they may be
killed for it
because their identities are going to
leak that's gonna happen really quickly
at a minimum they have to leave
basically enter witness protection
in effect um
but this follows them for the rest of
their lives they have to live the rest
of their lives looking over their
shoulder
to come back with acquittal in a
situation like that
would require i mean immense
it would be one of the
greatest examples of moral courage i
think that we've seen in modern times
really um just to sim to
to follow the evidence and do your job
knowing knowing what's going to happen
because of it
most people don't have that kind of
moral courage i don't know if i have it
like i said i'd be trying to get off the
jury
i got a family i gotta i gotta look out
for now by the way
um hours after maxine waters
said we have to get more confrontational
there was a drive-by shooting against
the national guard in the city
hours later so
i mean do we know that they did that
because what maxine water said
no but they certainly are following her
recommendation they're getting more
confrontational
how do you get more confrontational
burning down buildings well start
shooting at the cops i guess
the blm they've been they've been doing
that
but do it more yeah that's one way
remember trump at january 6th that his
uh
his speech to the crowd he actually said
the words
now you can speculate speculate all you
want about his intentions and everything
else but he did say the words
uh peaceful he said we have to go
whatever whatever the exact phrase was i
know for sure he said the word peaceful
we have to speak out peacefully you know
about about this he said
words to that effect but he put the word
peaceful in there
so all you're left with is speculation
that yeah he said peacefully didn't
really mean it and he knew that the
people in the crowd would interpret it
that way
well notice with these democrats they're
not even
they're not even bothering to say
peaceful with a wink
they could say that and it would
actually make a difference
if maxine waters had had flown in from
dc and said listen guys
we're really upset about this and so on
and so forth validating all their their
emotions
but we we have to be peaceful this is
not the way to go about this
she had said something simple like that
it would have made a difference
but she doesn't want peace
it is um the omission of that word
it almost doesn't matter anything else
she says the fact that
the the the deafening silence from
democrats that they will not come out
and even say
let's be peaceful well i hope you
enjoyed that clip from the matt well
show if you did
go ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content